what do I know about being a spiritual
leader what is it you're holding a
cookie you were chosen to become
something more than you already
are hello everybody and welcome to
Fandango's Big Ticket interview I am
here with the stars of Kung Fu Panda 4
Aquafina and Jack
Black hi you have to keep giving
yourselves props because you in the
rarified air of being in a franchise
that's made it to movie for
huge so I want to ask the newcomer and
the veteran of the franchise why do you
think that is why do you think it's made
it to four what's so special about the
panda I I personally I I am a huge fan
of of it independently and then you know
when I got the call I was so happy and I
think it's be I think it's because as a
fan it just well first of all it's I
think jacket is finest I think that you
know and there's a brand and level of of
humor in it where it's it's very free
and also also a nod I think to you know
certain cultural Traditions that are
very like true um so yeah i' I've always
loved it as a as a kid growing up it's
very heartfelt it is very heartfelt yeah
yeah I think I think people just love
Kung Fu they love that action they love
the genre and uh it's a cool way to
bring it to kids you know that that
aren't even aware of the Jackie Chan
films or the Bruce Lee films or the
Steven Chow films there's just such a
great Rich tradition of kung fu Cinema
yeah and uh to bring that with some
great animation and some comedy it's a
great combo so I'm going to stick with
you jack I feel like the words scoo and
Jack Black are just Kismet so at this
point in four how many ways and how many
times in a row can you say in a
different way can you say sco I can use
it in literally infinite ways okay go
for it oh wait okay so the first way
that just off the top of my head is hi
how you doing SC
SC I like that you just sounds like a
different language uh and here's one
where uh this tomato tastes
rotten SC oh oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh here's one like uh you
talking to me are we about to
brawl
scoo right you see what I mean I mean I
could go all day if someone's telling
you like crazy news SC oh oh oh oh like
yeah what if it what if it's the best
news you've ever heard in your
life what if you about green lit for a
Kung Fu Panda five scoo
yeah we could literally go all day with
this it's too much we better move on fun
we should we should move on um or
another way to say it is
skish and and that's
it it right yeah yeah yeah you can't
believe it yeah I love that talk a
little bit about who your character is
and what she brings to this franchise
and how is she a great counterpart to PO
my character Jen is is a well she's a
criminal uh Fox she definitely likes to
she got Sticky Fingers if you will um
and I think that she's also like complex
you know like yes she she corts in not
the best kinds of activities but also I
think that she is real and um I think
that as a partner to PO I like how she
like roasts him constantly and also
comes to really uh like him and and they
and I think that they do really form an
authentic friendship were you in the
booth together did you get to record
together at all a little bit yeah yeah
which was really cool okay I want to
talk about the booth style because I
have seen the YouTube videos of you sir
you get very calisthenic in the booth
you go full you do move what is your
sort of like getting into Panda mode
style and how does sort of like the
physicality feel free to demonstrate get
you into po mode oh you want me to
demonstrate oh I do that usually costs
extra but I'm going to give it to you
free uh first you got to do some
stretches uh otherwise you know you
could risk injury right uh so I like to
do just some straight up uh uh what's
these called again that's just like a
lower your upper half I think it's
called um hammies
ham oh and
then uh I like to get all of the change
out of my pocket just in case there's a
jingly jangly right you don't get poked
but if doing Kung Fu while he's talking
I'm going to do kung fu while I'm
talking it's the only way to get the
proper performance right so are you a
Kung Fu Master at this point you've done
so much of it Mastery takes thousands of
hours they say it's been scientifically
proven you have to do 10,000 hours I've
not done 10,000 hours of kung fu if I'm
honest with you it's probably in the
single digits but I have done some Kung
Fu youve done some the slow kind it's
called taii ta have you ta I done Tred
yeah yeah it's cool it's fun it's not
just for old people in the park it's all
it's for anybody it's for Kung Fu
Masters too see those old people in the
park you go oh that's cool is that like
yoga are they stretching no they're
actually doing slow motion deadly Kung
Fu it's like the it's like therapy for
therapist you know how the therapist
have a therapist it's moving
Chi yeah and then and then you put and
then you can you can push it out it's
spiritual right this actually feels
really good yes and it's like a dance it
is like a dance yes and Jack Black leads
our guided meditation for today ladies
and gentlemen how I proved my point that
I'm very good at Kung Fu what is your
booth style and how did you sort do you
sort of like have to amp yourself up do
you have an Anthem do you have a
playlist anything that you listen to I
don't know um I li you listen to great
stuff oh I do not not before the not
before the myself I always hope that it
works out as long as my I have I have a
voice you know I didn't do karaoke the
night before which is I think the worst
thing you know but other than that I I I
show up and you know sign the SAG sheet
and you know LED myself to the
experience more of an understated style
what would you give your character as
their sort of like song If you could if
I could give my character a song Take it
Easy by The Eagles wow unexpected that
was an unexpected Choice yeah I love the
I love the eagle
they got good harmonies yeah cuz I was
thinking when she just asked you that
question I was thinking I'm a Survivor
I'm on to make it and some the rest of
that song really well just cuz Jen is a
Survivor you know what I mean she's from
the streets and she's just going to
scrape and scrub and survive on that
mode along those lines your uh other
Universal project Super Mario Brothers
Peach's song Golden Globe nominated
congratulations
was Bowser themed song he did not find
inner pece however po has found inner
pece what do you think is on Po's
playlist number one wow Po Po's Good
Times um Bowser is more heavy metal PO
is more like I think po wants to dance
Rhythm of the Night it is a Rhythm of
the
Night how does that go you got to show
me love don't know that one okay this is
been of the karaoke Rhythm of the Night
I like Rhythm of the Night that's a good
one for po so we know po loves noodles
I'm wondering for each of you if there's
something that you could say you love as
much as po loves noodles I got one yeah
deviled eggs all day long I could crush
a Dev I think I could enter if there was
a deviled egg competish like who can eat
the most I'll take anyone down anyone
here on this set right now there's like
a 100 people here I'll take you all down
I don't think anyone would wanted to
compete and I also don't think anyone
would would want to watch that devil
eggs tastes so good they've done right
um also I think oysters I could eat
Infinity
oysters it's weird the smoth texture
yeah the two things you like are like
the worst things that you get at a gas
station you know what I mean no do not
get gas station oysters deviled eggs or
oysters dude I mean for real but I
oysters you got to go quality you don't
want to save money on oysters get the
get the good ones yes yes or to get them
yourself or you will regret yes but you
know what I mean like oysters when I eat
them I'm like this is nothing I don't
think this actually I don't think I ever
get full how many oysters do you want
Infinity just bring them never stop both
of your characters well po finds inner
peace in this film so I'm wondering what
actually brings each of you inner peace
tonight's going to be a good night
tonight's going to be a good good night
you R to Rock You Dev it up that would
be a good Jam I think for po oh we're
going back oh okay yeah I went back I
couldn't I couldn't leave that one alone
that song brings him inner peace it's
not a bad one for po I don't know I'm me
think some more about it that's more
like a wedding flash mob dance you know
but um what's that one that Elton John
sings about Saturday night's all right
for fighting I guess I'm going to kick
some cuz Saturday night's all right for
fighting that's a good Kung Fu Panda
right cuz it's all right you're going to
call me tomorrow aren't you and be like
I got it I know what the song is don't
ask me for a playlist cuz it will haunt
my dreams I got to get that perfect song
anybody here have any ideas for a Kung
Fu Panda Jam that would be perfect for
they're they're under strict orders not
to make any noise yes they are abely I
know they're thinking about my playlist
though they are I really want to hear
noodles noodles noodles in replace of
peaches peaches peaches I know you do I
really that costs extra noodles noodles
noodles noodles noodles that's also like
a tongue twister is it say it say
noodles five times fast Noles noodles
Noles yeah you're right exactly never it
goes into the Z you end up going Nels
after a while
schles um inner peace I'll go back to
that question we can go back to playlist
but yeah what brings each of you inner
peace I get Inner Peace
from like what I'm like when I'm
sleeping when I'm napping or sleeping
cuz I'm not you know I'm not awake you
know do you get do you get good snoozle
berries no I don't you don't sleep well
naturally I get I get like a really
demented seven hours okay but do you do
you have trouble like going to sleep at
night when it's bedtime yes and you're
like wait I have five hours until I have
to be up doing like the junk it and then
you watch go to sleep now yeah one more
game of Zombies versus Plants yes right
my thing is I like to lay down on the
ground and just try to relax it all you
ever do that yeah I love laying I
actually like the ground it's like at
the end of like a workout or a yoga sesh
or whatever just laying on the ground
it's like it sounds so dumb because it's
so obvious right I find inner peace and
just laying on the ground and just
letting it all I feel that melt it's not
sleeping but it's like right next door
now I'm picturing it should I do it now
yeah that's not a good interview you
don't want to see me laying down on my
back I'll never say no to you doing any
sort of Impressions demonstrations
anything like that maybe at the end of
the interview dude you know what another
good thing for inner peace what if you
float in the
ocean dude with a horizon in the
distance MH it's real meditative you
feel Mother Nature just carrying
you until you get sucked down by the
undertoe that's and the shark nibbles at
your
bits let's talk about the new your new
addition to the cast but we also have a
few more additions to the cast Oscar
winner key is in this film as well as
Viola Davis who's really in her
channeling her inner
evil um so talk a little bit about what
they bring to this new film I think it's
so awesome the the newcast additions and
also um well I don't know if this was
announced but like Ronnie Chang and and
Lori tanin uh as well as as key and V
who who plays a such a good evil villain
a villain character yeah she plays the
chameleon I actually have another
question about that um I'm not going to
do the usual uh Shape Shifter question
if you could shape shift at anybody for
a day I'm going to do the reverse if you
could assign anybody in Hollywood to
assume your body and be you for a day
and let them lose who would you like to
see let them lose like let them be you
for a day let them loose yeah not let
them lose let them loose and see what
they and see sort of like what they did
who would you choose wow oh jeez wow
well I'll just go I I love me some uh
some hen Phoenix yeah I'd love to see
what he could do with this body and just
let him
loose I mean that's the question it's
like who's your favorite person and then
just plug them into you and see what see
what they can do with this this Ferrari
m
who who would you put to put pick I I
don't know why but Jane Goodall I don't
know why that keeps coming up because
she's rad yeah yeah she worked with the
gorillas in the midst uh yeah which was
my favorite movie growing up what a
brave soul yeah I would love for her to
inhabit my body if she's down obviously
yeah I bet she would yeah I mean I I
mean I think she would in like a second
she like 100 years old she would be like
yes please Switcher roon no no I let her
have it I think she's incredible Choice
well done well done so both of your
characters are sort of unlikely Heroes
one became started as a noodle maker the
other one started as a thief become
unlikely Heroes can you equate that at
all to sort of like your careers or a
scent in Hollywood sort of starting
small and sort of what it's become I can
definitely relate in a sense of like
when they make their Journey or for PO
for instance there also is a pressure
right that comes with also you know
making it so to speak right um so you
know po kind of has to continue on
fighting for good and like keeping the
peace and like you know upholding stuff
so I think that's that's that can be
said about a lot of things in the
industry I just feel so fortunate I
think it's like I was thinking about
this the other day you know how all
movies now are in the Multiverse yes
this is a new phenomenon right there
were no Multiverse Movies 10 years ago
sliding doors was that the okay oh
sliding doors might have been the first
and like Scrooged SC the whole like plot
of Scrooge okay you're destroying my
whole FIS here Multiverse was brand new
but um I was thinking what in the
Multiverse other versions of me would be
more fortunate and more like blessed and
I don't think there is one I think this
is the best Multiverse uh I could be in
uh and I think uh the same is true for
po you see how I wrapped that up right
into your question answer you did that
was a thing of beauty you're
smome give the audience a little tease
of what to expect in this film and how
does it distinguish itself from the
first three well for one thing Po's got
more gray hairs now or white hairs did
you notice that the whole head's white
yeah the whole head's white but it's not
just that it's like if you look at his
fur in his black in his black hairs you
see some white hair and and it it
represents his maturity
and he's taken on some new
responsibilities and he's transitioning
away from the Kung Fu Dragon Master into
now the spiritual leader and he's not
quite sure he's ready for that new
growth so it just goes to show no matter
where you are in your life there's
always another level to take it to now
it's time to transfer into this stage of
your life and and that's kind of where
he's at and and uh and his insecurity
about that is a big part of this movie
for for for po that was that was
beautiful too oh man that was beautiful
did I get an A+ yes anything to add as a
newcomer to it and sort of the
experience of it all yeah I think this
one I mean this I I I think this one is
a great addition to it I think that
they're like Jack said the characters
that we've come to really know and love
are changing and heading to their new
you know heading to the next phase of of
their lives as we all are but I I think
the cast is really great and I think
that the animation is is killer we've
seen some pretty incredible animals as
foes in Kung Fu Panda five potentially
what animals would you like to see your
characters go up against oh my God we're
about to write the villainous characters
for Kung Fu Panda 5 Prett much it hasn't
even been green lit yet a lur a lemur oh
a lemur see you say lamur and I say le
lamur as well is it lur say lamur I say
lemur um if I was going to pick any
animal from the Animal Kingdom to be a
villain gosh God I guess I'm going to go
sent
wow things are scary if you look at them
close up have you ever checked out like
photographs of a centipede closeup on
the face
no Devils just Satan in that those
things are the scariest things ever and
if you had like a big one it would be a
great villainous character but it goes
so slow be like a logo motive not in my
imagination they move lightning fast
fast but they're
they're terrifying yeah the pincers
their
mouths
face I'll Google it I'll show you later
it'll haunt your dreams you like Kevin
Hart's afraid of insects by the way yes
he is for good reason yes how did you
know that because we did Jumanji oh
right oh that's right that's right
that's right um people are going to see
this in the theaters what would you
recommend as a sort of great like Poe
what should people eat getting ready for
this
movie I think uh you're going to want to
go with a nice Chinese chicken salad oh
that's just my go-to that's what I'm
having for lunch what are you having I
I'm going to have that as well you were
yeah yeah
gmta great m v think Alik um I I don't
know if this is a movie where you should
go and well I might eat during it right
but maybe don't eat anything so that
after afterwards you can go get a a big
nice meal or popcorn noodles wait a
second do you think what I'm thinking a
nice big
b wow that was a big one that how'd you
get all all your mouth oh you ate hary
you you see that every single kernel
went right into my mouth when did you
learn that Talent dude incredible it's
uh it's something that comes with years
of practice right cuz I say all eight of
them made it in your
mouth
that was a thing of beauty and on that
note thank you both for joining thank
you very nice to talk to you both and
reminding everybody that tickets for
Kung Fu Panda 4 are on sale now at
Fandango get them scush
sco